[Music]
julianne hough opens up about coming
back to music and her fight against
endometriosis and Demetrius is sort of
to me a commonality in women that nobody
really talks about but it's also a
bigger point of view of just life like
it's something that we there's a lot of
people that have it but don't speak up
and I think in just cultural experience
right now like we're starting to use our
voice as women it just says culture and
so I think for me endometriosis has been
my platform but I really am just as a
component of everybody being accepted
and loving themselves taking care of
themselves transformation and I'm
excited because for a long time I
haven't done my music and set that aside
and now I'm like embracing it with full
vengence and and it is it's all about
transformation and women and empowerment
and so I'm excited to be I'm excited to
be living right now I just wanted to
talk about Horsemen here for the best
new artist was there anyone in
particular that you're rooting for oh my
gosh I mean I was just in Phoebe's
brunch this morning and what she's doing
just empowering women and
um bringing light to the fact that even
this year we have had so many female
songwriters and female artists at the
top of the charts like crushing it so I
don't know I just I I love her she has
worked her ass off for so many years as
well she's been around I think she's a
shoot since she was like 14 and just
like paid her dues and she's 29 and
killing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]